[Musik]
vom börsenstar zum pleitefall der
zahlungsdienstleister wirecard beantragt
insolvenz
ja zum rettungspaket die lufthansa
aktionäre stimmen für die hilfen und den
einstieg des staates wie im schlimmsten
zeiten in den usa hat die zahl der
korona neuinfektionen wieder höchstwerte
erreicht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster mit narben ich begrüße
sehr zur heute sendung norbert lehmann
ist mit dem studio und hat das
wichtigste vom sport dabei einen schönen
namen doch von mir heute bestimmen
nachrichten aus der wirtschaft den tag
da ist einmal der skandal um die
verschwundenen milliarden bei wirecard
und die angemeldete insolvenz
und dann geht es noch um die zukunft von
lufthansa aber zunächst zum
zahlungsdienstleister wirecard vor
kurzem noch der deutsche star unter den
dax unternehmen jetzt steht er am
abgrund und mit ihm knapp 6000
mitarbeiter
was wirecard ist und macht erklärt
zunächst anselm stern
die zentrale von wirecard in aschheim
bei münchen ziemlich trist ganz im
gegenteil zur unternehmensgeschichte
lange ging es nur nach oben viele von
uns nutzen wirecard dienste wohl täglich
ohne es zu wissen wenn kunden online
oder an der ladenkasse mit karte zahlen
streckt wirecard den händlern das geld
vor und bekommt es später von den karten
unternehmen zurück dafür kassiert
wirecard eine provision ein
milliardengeschäft
so wurde das unternehmen zum liebling
der finanzmärkte 2018 klettert die aktie
auf fast 200 euro und vermindertes
wachstum versprach damals der chef am
dienstag wurde markus braun festgenommen
vorwurf bilanzfälschung und
marktmanipulation
der totale absturz an der börse die
einst so gefeierte wirecard aktie ist
heute so gut wie nichts mehr wert nun
also die insolvenz wegen überschuldung
und drohender zahlungsunfähigkeit was zu
weiteren panikverkäufen an der
frankfurter börse führte der wert der
aktie nur noch vier euro betroffen sind
banken die wirecard geld geliehen haben
und jede menge kleinaktionäre alexander
pohl vom aushängeschild zum buhmann in
rekordzeit hat der zahlungsdienstleister
wirecard sein renommee verspielt
fast zwei milliarden euro bilanzsumme
wahrscheinlich frei erfunden
markus braun die schillernde gründer
figur hatte kurz vor seiner festnahme
noch schnell seine eigenen aktien
verkauft der wirtschaftsprüfer ernst &
young sieht einen weltumspannenden
betrugsfall
das problem er selbst hatte wirecard
noch 2018 ein einwandfreies zeugnis
ausgestellt
sofern festgestellt wird dass
jahresabschlüsse in der vergangenheit
tatsächlich auch manipuliert gewesen
sind und dies für den wirtschaftsprüfer
erkennbar gewesen wäre muss das system
der vergabe von prüfaufträgen sicherlich
in frage gestellt werden heißt
unternehmen sollten sich künftig nicht
mehr selbst aussuchen dürfen wer sie
überprüft auch die staatliche aufsicht
steht massiv in der kritik das
bundesfinanzministerium überlegt die
kompetenzen für die bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht
auszuweiten
wirecard sagen experten habe den
börsenstandort deutschland massiv
erschüttert das bedeutet zunächst mal
dass das vertrauen der anleger in die
funktionsfähigkeit der kapitalmärkte
ganz massiv beeinträchtigt wird wir tun
alles um anleger an den kapitalmarkt zu
holen und all das wird nun zunichte
gemacht durch diesen dramatischen fall
der vor allem kleinanleger betrifft
tausende aktionäre deren wirecard-aktien
nur noch wenige euro wert sind für sie
gibt es zumindest einen kleinen
hoffnungsschimmer
ein aktionär hat auch ansprüche wenn
betrügerische sachen nachgewiesen werden
können zb die verletzung von ad hoc
pflichten dann haben sie
schadensersatzansprüche alle beteiligten
so scheint es müssen sich nach dem fall
wirecard unangenehme fragen stellen
lassen
ja wir fragen frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse wie kann so etwas
eigentlich passieren hatte niemand
genauer hingesehen
ja das fragt man sich längst auch in
berlin in der kommenden woche muss der
chef der finanzaufsicht bafin felix who
fällt nun zum rapport vor den
finanzausschuss die bafin ist massiv in
die kritik geraten weil sie schon länger
von unregelmäßigkeiten bei wirecard
wusste man habe zu ineffektiv gearbeitet
gibt die behörde selbst kritisch zu
bereits seit ende 2009 10 also vor fast
anderthalb jahren habe man
entsprechende dokumente zugespielt
bekommen dann ermittelt aber erst ein
jahr später also anfang diesen jahres
den verdacht der marktmanipulation an
die staatsanwaltschaft weitergeleitet da
also ist wertvolle zeit verschenkt
wurden inzwischen geht es ja auch um die
bilanzfälschung und da muss man fragen
baum haben dass die renommierten
wirtschaftsprüfer von ernst young
jahrelang nicht spitz bekommen
wir haben schon ihren ernst young
spricht inzwischen von einem
ausgeklügelten weltumspannenden
betrugssystem durch das auch sie hinters
licht geführt worden
aber ob sie mit der argumentation
durchkommen ist sehr fraglich fakt ist
sie hatten eine große verantwortung erst
als sich die wirtschaftsprüfer endgültig
weigerten die bilanz zu unterschreiben
flug der milliarden schwindel bei
wirecard auf danke für ihre erklärung
frank zu einem anderen schwer
angeschlagenen unternehmen der lufthansa
da haben die aktionäre jetzt entschieden
der staat darf der fluggesellschaft
helfen und zwar mit einem rettungspaket
von neun milliarden euro
da in der korona krise kaum noch
geflogen wurde sind tausende jobs
gefährdet im gegenzug darf im gegenzug
für die hilfen darf sich der staat an
dem unternehmen beteiligen und so
verlangt die eu lufthansa muss start und
landerechte abgeben stefan schlosser es
geht um ihre jobs es geht um die
existenz ihres unternehmens das ist
allen mitarbeitern der lufthansa klar
die vergangenen wochen haben an den
nerven gezehrt nachricht am nächsten
kommen die nachricht dass alles wieder
zunichte macht das hat er sehr eng
verbunden
mit unserer lufthansa und natürlich
schwingt die angst immer mit wird
langsam zeit dass eine unterschrift
drunter gemacht wird und wir alle wieder
in die luft dürfen
dafür war auch lufthansa-chef spohr in
seiner rede an die aktionäre
eine insolvenz der lufthansa auch in der
sonderform des schutzschirm verfahrens
hätte für sie meine damen und herren den
nahezu vollständigen verlust ihres
aktienkapitals zufolge offenbar bei
überzeugen die aktionäre stimmten für
die annahme des rettungspakets insgesamt
stehen neun milliarden euro staatshilfe
bereit in form von krediten einer
stillen beteiligung und einem
aktienanteil von 20 prozent
mitbestimmung soll es nicht geben
beobachter sind aber skeptisch
es werden ja auch zwei vertreter des
staates dann im aufsichtsrat einzug
halten
und das hat die gefahr dass politische
entscheidung mit einem eine rolle
spielen bei operativen entscheidungen
und die lufthansa muss frei sein
die mitarbeiter werden ihren teil zur
rettung beitragen in der nacht einigten
sich bereits die flugbegleiter
gewerkschaft und die lufthansa auf ein
sparpaket von über 500 millionen euro
und auch die piloten wollen auf geld
verzichten 850 millionen euro stehen im
raum rettungspaket angenommen
erleichterung bei der kabinen
gewerkschaft es ist ein klares signal
der aktionäre dass die lufthansa selbst
bestimmt gemeinsam mit den mitarbeitern
durch diese krise gehen soll
die kabine hat dafür schon einen beitrag
geleistet jetzt wird sich zeigen ob die
anderen mitarbeiter dass er auch schon
die lufthansa ist erst einmal gerettet
der kranich bleibt in der luft zur
corona pandemie eine beruhigende
nachricht aus dem brennpunkt gütersloh
fast alle massentests bei der
bevölkerung fielen negativ aus
von 2000 getesteten personen waren nur
eine infiziert bislang weniger
beleuchtet ist die situation der viel
wird durch den produktionsstopp beim
fleischproduzenten tennis wissen sie
nicht wohin mit tausenden schlachtreifen
tieren heiko rams und thomas münten
bauer rainer döinghaus aus langenfeld
bei rheda-wiedenbrück wiegt seine
schweine wenn das schlachtgewicht elf
monate nach der zeugung erreicht es
müssen die tiere raus denn sonst wird es
im stall zu voll
laufend kommen neue kleine ferkel dazu
wir sind in der glücklichen lage dass
wir noch ein bisschen sehr warm aber
eben nicht langfristig wir haben
vielleicht noch eine woche bis 14 tage
platz also die vier tiere die jetzt zum
schlachthof gehen diese die entscheidung
ist vor elf monaten gefallen dass sie
jetzt so weit sind
wenn der platz im stall nicht ausreicht
droht den tieren zusätzlicher stress
erzählt der bauer die versorgung mit
wasser und nahrung wäre nicht mehr
sicher und es drohen längere fahrten zu
einem weiter entfernten schlachthof das
problem gibt es fast bundesweit so
musste turniers schlachtungen in einem
werk in kempten im allgäu stoppen denn
hier wird fleisch nachschub für die
zerlegung in rheda wiedenbrück
produziert und dieses werk ist wegen
corona geschlossen die folge die bauern
wissen nicht wohin mit ihren tieren es
gibt sie erst einmal festzuhalten dass
wir hier nicht eine tagesfrage
bearbeiten sie eine systemfrage
die zunehmende zentralisierung die
effiziente verarbeitung von fleisch
sorgt für eine sehr empfindliche kette
wenn ein glied ausfällt bericht die
kette zusammen es kommt zu tierschutz
verstoßen und auch darum soll es morgen
gehen bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin
klöckner will mit dem handel der
fleischwirtschaft und tierschützern in
düsseldorf über lehren aus der krise
beraten sie aber nicht nur in
schlachthöfen auch in anderen orten
häufen sich die korona infektion wo
diese sogenannten hot spots sind und was
sie gemeinsam haben erfahren sie in der
zdf- heute- app vor allem lokale
ereignisse wie der krone ausbruch bei
turniers lassen die zahl der neu
infizierten in deutschland weiter
steigen und das inzwischen schon seit
gut einer woche im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage haben sich 670
menschen täglich neu angesteckt gestern
lag der wert noch bei 600 von solchen
zahlen sind die usa jedoch weit entfernt
dort hat sich die lage erneut verschärft
die johns hopkins universität
registrierte gestern 34.000 3
100 neue infektionen fast so viele wie
zum höhepunkt der krise im april
insgesamt stieg die zahl der infizierten
auf knapp 2,4 millionen die meisten
neuinfektionen gibt es im süden des
landes wo die korona beschränkungen früh
gelockert worden
die kritik daran trifft auch den
präsidenten und das mitten im wahlkampf
immer thesen masken pflicht beschlossen
den palm beach county florida und schon
geht's los als wäre die maske ein
werkzeug der unterdrückung überall da wo
menschen sich weigern maske zu tragen wo
sie unvorsichtig sind schießen die
infektionszahlen in die höhe
auch die zahl der todesopfer wächst wie
hier in arizona menschen 20 30 40 jahre
alt geht es sehr schlecht manche sterben
der gouverneur von texas hatte früh mai
die beschränkungen gelockert jetzt sind
die krankenhäuser an der grenze und er
fleht es gibt keinen grund dass sie ihre
häuser verlassen außer wenn man es
wirklich muss wie wichtig die masken
sind zeigen die zahlen denn dort wo seit
wochen zehntausende demonstrierten die
meisten mit maske sind die
infektionsraten nicht deutlich
angestiegen anders als da wo die
menschen ohne jeden schutz zusammen
kamen auch noch angefeuert von donald
trump wie hier in arizona diese woche
bei einer studenten kundgebung fast ohne
maske der präsident reißt witze über den
namen der krankheit
woher denn bei coop 19 die 19 kommen
infizierte junge leute können ältere
anstecken experten rechnen mit 300.000
toten in 2020 die menschen müssen zu
hause bleiben ansonsten masken tragen
das ist der einzige weg um die kontrolle
ansatzweise zurückzugewinnen
die trump administration streicht
derweil die finanzhilfen für die
teststationen obwohl die pandemie jetzt
neu in fahrt kommt mehr als 43.000
corona opfer haben die briten inzwischen
zu beklagen
angesichts dessen sind die
verantwortlichen im land gerade entsetzt
über solche bilder von den
an der südküste bei hitze temperaturen
von über 30 grad drängen sich dort
zehntausende tagesausflügler auf engstem
raum
die lage sei nicht mehr beherrschbar
melden die einsatzkräfte und klagen über
das extrem aggressive verhalten der
strandbesucher nach tagelanger prüfungen
und einem gespräch mit der
bundeskanzlerin hat bundesinnenminister
seehofer entschieden er wird nun doch
nicht wie zunächst angekündigt
strafanzeige gegen eine kolumnistin der
taz erstatten aber erwünscht ein
gespräch mit der chefredaktion der
tageszeitung über die umstrittene
kolumne und ihre wirkung der angeblich
satirische text hatte unter anderem
polizisten mit müll verglichen
in den usa laufen mehr als 100000 klagen
gegen das deutsche unternehmen bayer
gestritten wird über den wirkstoff
glyphosat er soll krebserregend sein
jetzt hat bayer einen großen teil der
verfahren beendet für mehr als zehn
milliarden euro wurde ein vergleich
erreicht glyphosat ist in dem mittel
roundup enthalten und wird in der
landwirtschaft und in privaten gärten
eingesetzt
ein unabhängiges wissenschafts gremium
soll zudem feststellen ob es bei
korrekter anwendung wirklich
krebserregend ist nach russland da plant
die regierung ja eine verfassungsreform
und eigentlich ist die sache schon
entschieden
trotzdem sind ab heute auch die wähler
gefragt sechs tage lang dürfen sie
abstimmen über ein voll gepacktes paket
es geht etwa um rentenerhöhungen oder
darum dass auch künftig nur mann und
frau heiraten dürfen
es gibt aber auch einen passus extra für
wladimir putin vor 20 jahren wurde er
zum ersten mal präsident nach der reform
könnte er es bis 2036 bleiben
christiansen der wahlhelfer in russlands
wildem osten ist muss lust auf abenteuer
haben im ganzen land wird über die
umstrittenen verfassungsänderungen
abgestimmt auch in der region chabarowsk
weil die menschen in den abgelegenen
gebieten nicht zur wahlurne kommen
können kommt die wahlurne eben zu ihnen
wetterstation wird zum wahllokal ist
alles ungewöhnlich wir haben sommerhitze
nie kommen hubschrauber hierher geflogen
und auf einmal kommt einer zigaretten
haben sie mir mitgebracht
ob am straßenrand auf dem schiff am
gartenzaun oder im internet wählen geht
überall
der kreml will nichts unversucht lassen
für eine hohe zustimmung und
wahlbeobachter haben es schwer das alles
zu kontrollieren
sieben tage dauert die abstimmung bis
zum ersten juli
ich bin sehr stolz dass ich der erste
bin heute ich mache den anfang für eine
für uns alle wichtige sache neben
rentenerhöhung der ehe zwischen mann und
frau geht es vor allem um eins den
machterhalt von präsident putin der sich
gerade im umfragetief befindet die
korona krise hat auch russlands
wirtschaft hart getroffen mit der
verfassungsänderung könnte er noch bis
2036 weiterregieren
putins gegner sprechen von verfassungs
umsturz beteiligen sie sich nicht an
einem solchen unsinn
erstens verhöhnt ist die verfassung das
gesetz und die idee von walen und
zweitens werden sich dadurch massenhaft
leute mit corona infizieren die
verfassungsänderungen sind von putin und
dem parlament längst beschlossen einer
mehrheit bei der abstimmung scheint er
sich sicher zu sein
es wäre die legitimität des volkes und
im internet häufen sich die witze über
den ewigen präsidenten und unsere dir
norbert und zum fußball in england da
könnte heute abend ja die entscheidung
fallen ja allerdings sollte denn der
tabellenzweite manchester city gegen
chelsea nicht gewinnen ja dann haben
dass liverpool und trainer jürgen klopp
geschafft der sieg der reds gegen
crystal palace gestern abend macht die
vorzeitige meisterschaft heute abend
möglich nach dem stotterstart mit dem 0
0 gegen everton klopps team wieder im
turbo-modus dominant ja meisterlich
alexander arnold mit präzision zur
führung
rabin mitgefühl und salaam mit
kaltschnäuzigkeit 2 zu 0 zur pause
gegner crystal palace gute englische
mittelklasse völlig unterlegen nie vor
dem liverpool tor
stattdessen ein krachender fernschuss
von verbio und das 4 0 nach bild schönen
konter durch money ein vorzeitiges
meisterschafts feuerwerk
die mannschaft will das hat man in der
zeit gemerkt sie will es für unsere fans
die zu hause bleiben müssen
denn auch keine stimmungslosen kulisse
in rot und weiß getaucht das stadion aus
lautsprechern der fan gesang die erste
meisterschaft seit 30 jahren nur eine
frage von stunden bestenfalls tagen und
vor möglichen englische meister zum
deutschen vizemeister lucien favre
bleibt auch kommende saison bvb trainer
sein bis 2021 laufender vertrag wird
erfüllt teilte die vereinsführung heute
mit und nun weltmeisterliches die
nächste fifa frauen fußball wm 2022
werden australien und neuseeland
gemeinsam austragen
mitkonkurrent kolumbien ging leer aus
und basketball bundesliga das
finalturnier ist auf der zielgeraden
angekommen
denn nach ludwigsburg steht jetzt auch
alba berlin im endspiel
zufriedenheit bei den berliner nach dem
klaren sieg auch im halbfinal-rückspiel
gegen oldenburg in blau kann nur zu
beginn ansatzweise mithalten
berlins trainer renaissance beobachtet
gelassen die sein team wie erwartet das
spiel dominiert 65 zu 45 ende des
dritten viertels für den bei diesem
turnier noch ungeschlagenen pokalsieger
den letzten korb der partie macht
oldenburg endstand 81 59 für berlin
auf der jagd nach dem ersten
meistertitel seit zwölf jahren freuen
sie sich nun auf das erste finalspiel
morgen gegen ludwigsburg morgen besser
ins spiel und das rückspiel und die
entscheidung dann am sonntag
danke norbert zum schluss noch ein blick
nach paris mehr als 100 tage steht er in
der korona krise da haben eisern aber
einsam der eiffelturm
nun sind die auflagen gelockert die tore
wieder offen
nicht aber die aufzüge hoch kommt man
nur stufe für stufe ein wichtiges
zeichen für frankreich langsam geht's
aufwärts bei besten aussichten so hofft
man ebenfalls ja beste oder zumindest
ganz gute sommerliche aussichten beim
stehen beim wetter auf dem programm
morgen allerdings einschließlich
gewitter
die einzelheiten hat gleich katja
horneffer so viel von uns danke für ihr
interesse
mehr gibt's später bei christian sievers
im heute journal um drei viertel ziehen
und uns gibt es morgen wieder punkt 19
uhr noch einen entspannten sommerlichen
abend für sie
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren das
tief rosemarie schaufelte heute viele
wolken zu unseren es kam allerdings auch
regenschauer und gewitter an zum
beispiel mecklenburg vorpommern aber
auch hier in südostbayern jetzt in der
nacht lockern sich die wolken mehr und
mehr auf und nur am alpenrand kann es
noch mal etwas regnen
es bildet sich in der feuchten luft auch
mal nebel und das wird eine laue
sommernacht besonders an den küsten von
ost und nordsee oder auch am rhein
da sinken die werte zum teil nicht unter
9 10 bis 17 grad deutlich kühler wird
die nacht in bayern mit elf bis 9 grad
und morgen klettern die temperaturen auf
schweißtreibende 25 grad an der ostsee
und bis 33 grad am rhein und schon am
vormittag geht das los mit regenschauern
und gewittern
die ziehen hier über ost sachsen
brandenburg und berlin bis nach
mecklenburg vorpommern und ab den
mittagsstunden beginnt es dann auch hier
im südwesten zu brodeln von frankreich
und luxemburg her breiten sich schauer
und gewitter aus es gibt allerdings auch
einen korridor für die sonne und der
liegt morgen zwischen sylt dem emsland
und dem bayerischen wald die gewitter
übrigens die können durchaus
unwettercharakter haben also mit hagel
platzregen und sturmböen verbunden sein
solche gewitter gibt es auch noch am
samstag der sonntag wird schon ruhiger
der montag kühler
schönen abend noch